[Music]
sports
can be an escape from watching at home
to hooping on the court
sports inspire reveal character and
bring people together
the old school had hank aaron breaking
the babe's record and kareem
sky hooking the lead into submission my
generation
will remember the extraordinary legacy
of sue bird and lebron james
lebron james leading the lakers to a
17th title
and the fourth in his remarkable career
sports
can make us feel invincible i remember
scoring my first touchdown as a kid
taking the handoff exploding through the
hole my locks flowing through the air
like i was stephen jackson in his prime
[Applause]
sports transcend the game jim brown
muhammad ali
and tommy smith they laid the foundation
and fought for equality so bubba wallace
chris paul and coco golf would have a
bigger platform today i'm fighting for
my future kids for my future
grandchildren
althea gibson walk so the williams
sisters could run
the world women in sports no longer take
a backseat
they drive the bus just ask genie laker
nation i look forward to celebrating
with you
as we watch today's event let us not
forget the power of sports
and what is possible sports have given
me the opportunity to have made me the
man i am today
i've learned that teamwork makes the
dream work now it's time for us to come
together
and be the dream that we need to be